herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
heute zusammen mit risiko das gab s noch
länger verletzt video was wir gemacht
haben war das letzte video was wir
gemacht haben was nicht
wir haben jede menge getränke oder wir
haben cola fanta sprite ist es nichts
bezahlt etwas umgang man das für uns
verrückten geburt folgen wir haben jede
menge richtet viel wenn wir lernen heute
versuchen die beliebtesten softdrinks
selbst zu machen fährt hier kommen bei
galileo das schwierigste der drei sachen
würde wenn ich mal die cola seine frau
würde sagen was vor warum reden fangen
wir einfach an wird der chor
ich lese ich heute zutatenliste für
kohle erzeugt und eine zitrone eine
nette zählt
logischerweise ist es nicht das original
rezept weil das ist ja eines der besten
gehüteten geheimnisse der welt sie sind
wirklich oder
doch wirklich als ob nicht pepsi wüsste
die cola funktioniert als hätten die das
nicht so eine geheimagentin rausgefunden
vor eine batterie hält man kann man im
hallo meine videos jetzt so ja wir
brauchen von zwei euro die unbehandelte
abgeriebene schale assouline die fans
freilich kommt schon mal direkt der
nächste schritt ist also eine große
zitrone die us-wirtschaft und dann auf
eine länger ich war fast zu weit
ganz europa wenn man das mal so im
profil dreht die haut von der rote ist
einfach komplett intakt ein konzertfilm
hätte gehört dass peter und anja kraska
und verblasen
soweit für 2001 spielte trainiert ich
zentrierte eine stärke von arnim
20 martinsried herz statt das nicht wäre
das nicht folgerichtig craig erhält aus
dem schlaf herr lohnt der richter so
aber hat das was mit cola zu tun nicht
so blöd wenn ich das nicht einfach nach
das zum saufen 22
das meinen hoffenheim eine fleischwunde
ist es darf wieder nein so ist es jetzt
her sinnvoll ablenken so passiert als
nächstes als nächstes eine zitrone und
von der liebe dramatisch wieder hoffen
echt krass ich habe dich gedacht ist ein
scharfes profil ist es war nämlich
marina und bernd krömer hat waren das
kommt bei dieser woche so viel wie mit
den tief
wenn man jetzt alles zusammen glaubt und
das kann nach cola
keine ahnung ich weiß halt das cola so
weit weg von allem was ich wann gibt man
riecht ja etwas existiert also ich komme
mit dem blutigen nicht gewährt also
würde auch so über medien schweine leute
wie sie es wirklich der beste reiber den
man sich nur vorstellen kann
er müsste unbedingt bei riese
vorbeischauen weil nur er reibt wieder
aus einer handbewegung nicht drauf wir
haben hier den geschnittenen ingwer ich
habe schon mal die vanille aus der
magnetische rausgeholt und natürlich
drittel waren wir mit der wir arbeiten
der sternanis sitze drückt und hier sind
die zehn tonnen schade die widrige
fleißig für uns raus vorbild gebt euch
das mal leute das sind zwei orangen und
eine zitrone
naja is back gehobelt unglaubliches
vorstellbar vor aber jetzt wirklich ich
wäre so krass überrascht wenn wir mit
gute kollegen bekommen das verkraftbar
stell dir mal vor so eine cola die noch
krass besser schmeckt weil die so wie
schmeckt die kohle aber eben etwas was
man frisch zu
wir werden einfach coca cola als
marktführer verdrängen getränkemarkt ich
stehe sagen so ein fahrrad muss die
ganzen rummel ich kann jetzt schon er
macht das ich froh bin
leute geht als sehr klein im vergleich
zum budget werden
die haben alle vorbereitungen getroffen
das hat auch nur 30 minuten genau wie
sie du kannst einmal ein achte teelöffel
zimt weil sie nicht wie man das so drauf
abmessen sollte dich eben eine
muskatnuss
wusstest du dass dann dadurch werden
kann daten muss raus was man hört aber
so richtig ich halte das für den 3 wenn
das führte dazu dass das heute macht
bist du eine psychoaktive substanz zeigt
man kann schön wenn man das rad jetzt
ist ein aktueller film muskatnuss ist
viel mehr als das was eine achtet hier
dafür durchaus auch ein 8 und teelöffel
die wir nach dem tier dafür kriegen wir
machen erstmal ein teelöffel überall
tieren wie dem und hat ihnen den
normalen und nochmal photoshop war
inklusive film pro liter wasser muss ich
jetzt einmal ermessen was für mich den
ultra messe 3000 stellen fehlt er uns
nützlich sind und warum das wasser ist
schon drin
das soll cola ergeben also ohne wir noch
wenn das wirklich eine cola ergibt dann
weil sie sonst nicht nach kohle auf das
solle cola werden war nicht wenig ganz
sicher ob das funktionieren würde ich
versuche dass wir meinen jetzt probieren
einmal auf um zu wissen wie es um
gekocht habe aus neugier und
wissenschaftlicher du musst ja nicht
wollten wir auch das wohl der kinder
merken wir willkommen
wir stellen diesen herren
bild 20 minuten köcheln und sehen uns
gleich wieder man selbst mal die frage
stellen wie entsteht eigentlich nur zu
kann ich kann nicht beantwortet
zuckerrohr komme eine vier bis sechs
zentimeter dickes glas den typischen
karamell geschmack perfekt ich habe
jetzt gerade rückwärts laufen lassen und
beschleunigt
man riet den geruch von heike kohler in
der luft ist einfach die schlüssel
kartensystem ist zeit schritt sieht
auslegen
dann müssen wir das vielleicht abseilen
ist schon mal vorab sein gehört oder
brahms sagen kenne ich als halte ich mal
darüber unterricht war ich doch bis
hierhin so ein bisschen nach einer cola
es hat echt so natürlich so max dagmar
über pech wir haben noch das steht
überhaupt nichts interessantes auch mal
zehn minuten die wir umbringen müssen um
die gehen jetzt los wir bringen müssen
noch warten denn das hier so leicht vor
sich hin köchelt er leute wenn ihr mal
zufällig in köln übrigens seit ich
blende ich die adresse von max 1
dann geht zum max und holt ein café ab
weil er macht sauguten café leute es
läuft alles kopf wie sagt man sollte
alles drunter drüber es beschissen ich
stelle jetzt diese mixtur die auch
wirklich schon anfängt nach cola zum
riechen in den anderen topf 1 und dann
vätern wir mit diesem tuch irgendwie
alles raus probieren das dann mit dem
zucker noch so verrückt das heißt einmal
kommt dass hier rein und läufst dann
einfach durch
ihr hört schon in den heißen topf rhein
und in den topf müssen der dann gleich
mit zucker dazugeben
wo steht das kocht voll ich glaube es
noch nicht kochen damit stellt sich in
der planung ist so schlau wie sowas will
ich über die sich kaum schützen ihn rein
aber das hätte nur zucker wir drücken
dass man ein bisschen aus du verrückt
dass ein bisschen ich hole derzeit mit
kamera so wir haben jetzt alles gekocht
der zucker ist verrührt wieso jetzt die
fahrerei nicht berühre dabei und dann
wird das alles der coder damit haben wir
absolut ist das gut ist das schon zu
viel doch alles einfach alles an alles
ist sicher dass skoda und das lassen wir
jetzt kurz stehen und dann ist gleich
mit mineralwasser vermischen und haben
unsere eigene coder der kopfhörer das
sieht auch gut aus
magna biete ich nicht also mit fertigen
irgend jemandem reden aber man sieht
also seine stilmittel
ich wünsche dass nun sehe könnte ich mir
schon fast vorstellen
das ist dann werden wir sehen ob es uns
gelungen ist selbst wenn du das jetzt so
heißt wie es ist kriegt sie dafür 50
jahre das heißt wir müssen das jetzt mit
google sozusagen mit spreewasser sollte
direkt testen es muss ja nicht gekühlt
werden
machen vier würde ich sagen weil ja muss
ja auch ohne männer merken
und wie sieht es auf seine vernichtung
ok bisschen bläulich im schau aber ich
würde sagen man könnte es wieder das
cola durchgehen lassen kopf beste video
geehrt leute das ist unsere cola also da
sind so aspekt ja ja ja aber was ist
weit weg und das heißt es classics rudel
was soll das sprudelwasser was
übertrieben viel sprudel hat dass der
sirup hat gemacht das ist gar nicht mehr
spielen
ich finde das lecker es hat so ein
bisschen ist also klar es hat mir meinen
dass wir eine vanilleschote drin wenn
man sich mal vorstellen das ist cola
vanille könnte man denken das ist
abgestanden dafür waren wir ein bisschen
habe ich möchte ein bisschen ab gestand
aber nicht also aber ein schlechter
leute macht es unbedingt nach es ist
jetzt nicht eklig oder so aber ich bin
eben fall erwartet brinkmann ich würde
immer was sowas vorziehen
das schmeckt werden möchtest du musst du
musst mit zeichensprache
jetzt habe ich vergessen
klick klick
so oder so cola wasser eis taut und
exakt so ich habe das früher her gerne
getrunken ist es also für die
lebensmittel bis heute ist das wird
natürlich bleibt wird sowieso wieder
zurück mussten ja nicht einfach umgehen
weil ich bin der am schlechtesten
vorbereiteten das kleine macher der welt
aber ich habe auf dem kontinent noch ein
paar wochen zu haben wir haben jetzt
zwei kilogramm zucker das ist nicht nur
ein kilogramm
das sehe ich anders das sind zwei
kilogramm nicht das war dann jetzt doch
dritter ist es mitbekommen nein da hat
so eine komische frau sich mail gekauft
hat es abgewogen und es hat man mit
verpacken vier damen zu wenig bogen und
verbraucherschutzzentrale hält irgendwas
getreten hatte ich so richtig
abgefragten man ist so was soll die
scheiße und alles komplett wahnsinnig 95
gramm bei der mama wird gar nichts wir
haben jetzt gerade bei cola festgestellt
obwohl es sohn auch wenn das rezept
freitag der zeitschrift ein wird einfach
die anderen das kann ja nur besser
werden wird viel besser deshalb auch
gehören 153 gramm einer zeit da wird ja
wir müssen das jetzt aus bachelor aber
wir haben so was nicht
manche leute damit so braucht sich zum
einen kommt jetzt kann ich selbst kann
die medien verkaufen habe
beispiele das sind wir müssen das jetzt
mal klein schneiden schneider durch
jetzt einfach drücken
ich habe mir gedacht nehmen nein das
bleibt es aber einen verpflichtet aber
der sport ob durch nein bleibt auch da
drin hängen
das hat ja super gut gemacht unterschied
ja dann kommen nur der saft raus
das kommt aufs gleiche raus nachdem
nicht existenten rezept steht das ist so
gut leute
weißt du was ich jetzt tue also kleine
stelle durchgeschnitten haben überlasse
man leider das mitleid daraus mittler
kündigen gesund profane grundlage geben
wir das ganze personal videoausschnitten
würde
hast du damit gerechnet dass diese aber
wegen wieder aufnimmt kommt mir ist
aufgefallen da ist limette und zitrone
drauf das heißt wir müssen auch noch die
limette rente jetzt nochmal nachricht ja
unglaublich großen und starken dass das
video wird so viel besser dadurch dass
so viele leute ja das ist er satt von
drei zitronen und die männer genau das
ist das geheimrezept jetzt stehen wir
doch den zucker von den jungferninseln
von den jugendlichen das hier löst sich
der zucker überhaupt augen einnehmen
doch nicht das schmeckt wirklich
überzeugt das wird gut das ist breit
ja ich wollte mal sehen das ist
tatsächlich soll der das könnte jetzt
nicht böse drin
das hier ist jetzt besser die
flüssigkeit ist egal aber das hier her
kommt es bei konzentrieren ich war ja
auch so falls in einem glas ist echt und
sagen auf die echt ist oder doch gerade
bei der kohle als nicht so gut unterwegs
mit es ist das richtige zeug macht uns
leute noch mit von dort naja grundlegend
anderes rezept
jetzt machen wir fand den rest von außen
also ich werde das jetzt einfach nur
rosa mit zucker was wir jetzt machen ist
fand was die wenigsten leute wissen klar
macht man mit normalen zucker aber macht
man mit puderzucker dazu kann ich noch
total wahrscheinlich schon aber wir
sprechen nicht darüber
wir haben das jetzt so weiter sind weil
die hoffnung ja auch mal ganz schön auch
nicht einfach die panther müssen wir
jetzt mit ein bisschen wasser jungs
schon glaubst du ja so schmeckt es noch
nichts das ist kurz ab denken so gut die
haben das recht eine rolle aber ich
finde das riecht auch noch fanta ob dann
zimmermann besteht ob man danach kommt
man weiß es nie erfahren werde ich neben
den ersten stück alles zu einem
verfahren genauer liefern
[Musik]
es schmeckt halt so wie der saft der
vieles sehr verdünnt ist und dann sind
nach außen gedrückt
ja wir kommen hier nicht raus bildern
ja ja ich weiß auch nicht was mit diesem
video passiert ist ich hoffe es war
lustig für euch die stand das ist drei
mal kurz vorm nervenzusammenbruch
wir beenden das an dieser stelle wenn
ihr teil zwei folgen mit serien ab pepsi
und mirinda carfrae kann sein verlag
jeden fall leichter shopping bei mir
vorbei alle anderen die plötzlich im
video aufgetaucht sind natürlich auch
unten in der video beschreibung für eine
ganz tolle leute ruhig zugehen auch mal
raus an
peter das werden sie zwischendurch
gegangen aber das bekommen wir sehen uns
gut und bis dahin tschüss